ladies and gentlemen we're gonna watch
brooklyn nine
nine today season one episode 12.
pontiac bandit if you guys
like what you see make sure to hit that
like button
and also make sure to subscribe and
click that notification
bell don't be stupid also
big thanks super thumb gin doll for
editing down the highlights for us
buddy full length watch along so you
sync up with the time code
for brooklyn nine nine over at our
patreon page
so you got many shows over there with
the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch alongs included
and uh i i think that's everything ah
this is just like my trip to new york
[Music]
pretty sweet scooter oh yeah i know
check out these donuts
oh i picked up a couple of reacher
grabbers yeah
so i'm able to do everything that i used
to do eh
okay just got a
[Applause]
hey charles just take my coffee it's
fresh okay i guess i mean if you don't
mind
all right you got it yeah that's right
no problem why wouldn't you just use
your other hand
oh cold milk oh it's coming out the
bottom
it is coming off the bottom of the
podcast
what happens if you get like a bunch of
liquid inside of a cast
answer in the comments
it seems like something that would be
detrimental
yeah what's going on just picked him up
on a dozen counts of identity theft
his name's doug
what do you do to these perps fear is a
powerful aphrodisiac
he said he wants to speak to quote john
or jack peralta or whatever
there's information about some dude who
steals pontiacs
hey diaz come in here talk to me
this dude is super horny yeah he's good
at playing horny
he is i synced it
backing up guys oh are you huh please
get out of my way
sorry sorry well you don't have to
apologize for anything boyle you were
shot in the line of duty defending
a fellow doctor said that if the bullet
was two millimeters to the left and a
foot higher i might never have walked
again
we all want your first day back to be as
pleasant and as comfortable as possible
right detectives absolutely ouch
you ran over my foot i am in incredible
pain
the pontiac bandit is my nemesis i've
been chasing this guy for eight years
he's stolen hundreds of cars all of them
pontiac
oh he's the pontiac bandit isn't it it's
gotta be
yeah feeding info so would you say he
looks sort of like
this that's bill this is a composite
sketch from 10 interviews i've done
anything else i'm not gonna get in touch
with him doug judy
[Music]
you wanted to see me captain my
husband's dog should have had relations
with a neighbor dog karate and produce
these twos
he insisted that i find them a good home
with someone
dogs are my whole life also work please
don't be allergic
the option no you're allergic to dogs
aren't you
nope i just need an epipen because my
happiness is making my throat close up
no
hand me the small dog santiago small dog
he's agreed to help us catch the bandit
if we drop all charges against him
how many cars would you say this pontiac
bandit has stolen 230 that i know of
the real number could be in the millions
you're not very good at math
[Laughter]
really especially in new york
do you guys caught him it's your call
look this guy is for real
a thousand push-ups a thousand push-ups
really what's a thousand push-ups
oh we were in the academy together and
we hated all the drills so now when
we're on a case and one of us does a
thousand push-ups
it means i'm so sure i'm right that if
i'm wrong i'll do a thousand push-ups
oh no i've got you now pontiac bandit
no no he's gonna do a thousand push-ups
he's absolutely good
or maybe they'll both do a thousand
push-ups my mom's car's here
she's home i gotta take these cups off
she doesn't know i'm a criminal
she thinks i own an architecture firm
with all white employees
fine one false move and i tase you in
front of your mom
mama this is my girlfriend rosie oh
no and this is my personal assistant
mangy carl ah nice to meet you you can
just call me carl
mangy carl used to be a homeless
gentleman i work with a charity that
finds jobs for downing and luck white
people
oh just a big old angel he's been so
good to
the white
no bites back in the game
when can we meet how long till he
usually gets back to you hmm like 10
minutes
it's him parking lot on flatbush and
vanderbilt in 15 minutes
let's go wait wait wait diaz looks like
a dirty criminal but you look like a cop
man you can't go over there like that
what'd you have in mind don't call it a
comeback no no
gina we've been looking all over for you
you can't just disappear and leave a
sign on your desk that says gone leaving
calmly it's safe in here cause the
scooter can't get up the steps in the
hallway
gina have some compassion boyle got hurt
doing something brave
this is my home now i gotta say
the suit is growing on me looks good is
it triple breasted somehow
there's no such thing what about the
girl in total recall
triple d
there's no sign of anyone
a thousand push-ups okay oh
man who the hell are you where's bill
he hadn't heard from me in a while so he
sent me to make sure everything was cool
who are they this is the buyer carl
management what's up i don't know them
i don't trust them he meets with you
alone or it's off
i'll text the address you send them in
aloud no we do not something doesn't
smell right to me
it could be my dad's suit he died in it
he died in it
oh man nah he's just trying to get away
scot-free
they just sent the location man this
dude is cautious if i show him one
minute late or i'm not alone
he's done with me i can't let the
pontiac bandit get away
put a wire on him get a tactical team in
his backup it's the only way
doug judy and i know this guy you have
to trust us do i
one of you is a criminal and the other
one is dressed like steve harvey
it's over sorry jake seriously
yeah thousand push-ups well i raised you
2000 push-ups
no no dude will i break the pact
i hope you understand how serious this
is to me come on rosa
can't you read between the lines man
don't quote die hard
sorry but we're still sending him in
alone
oh rosa looks good this episode
always looking great so what'd i miss
tell me all the jokes everything funny
that happened
charles you really need to get back to
hitchcock called himself scully by
accident
i did but it brought me and scully
closer together
it's great oh no i laughed too hard
lost another highlighter they don't have
skinny forearms
fine oh great
yeah it's way down there by my butt oh
yeah yeah yeah that's it is that it yep
oh okay right there no got it
oh my god where's my grandmother's ring
no
found it i'll be right back
welcome to the boil-free zone please
turn off all
cell phones so as not to attract any
unwanted attention
i still think he's him we meet at last
pontiac bandit
for eight years i've tracked you doug
judy can you hear me say something to
test the wire hey diaz
after we put the cuffs on this guy i'll
be free for dinner
you like spaghetti and weed
my man what's up pleasure to see you
again
let's talk about cars i got my shop up
and running again
you know cars cars
i'm talking about cars they take you
places
where's everyone hiding from me in the
evidence room
ruined downton abbey for me
i would have just stayed at home but i
was getting lonely and bored one day i
looked out the window for four hours
i didn't see anything yeah puppets
and puppies how do they stop how they
start
that's it i'm calling it no move people
we're going in now
it's a recording yeah it's kind of
something nypd down here gotcha pontiac
bandit
where's doug judy he went to the
bathroom i'm just here to give him a
haircut i don't know what's going on
he's gone he ran why would he do that he
helped us catch the pontiac bandit that
was the deal doesn't make any sense
unless
doug judy is the pontiac bandit
a news it so if you're the pontiac
bandit who's this joker
a couple of years ago you were getting
really close so i started telling all my
associates if they ever get caught
they should describe me as asian dude 5v
spiky hair wears diamond earrings and
has a british accent so then you hired a
guy who matched that exact description
no no no no that's my barber norman lee
he gave me the idea
you know if you can't come in i do house
calls you just text me location and i
could be there in half an hour
good to know basement connected to
another basement which connected to a
garage
which is where my boy picked me up your
boy guy from the meetup
he works for you what why don't you come
back here and take me out to dinner
i know you're trying to trap me but
crazy thing is
i'm tempted of course you are
maybe we could have been friends in
another world if i hadn't just fooled
you
like a little [ __ ]
okay let's send cops out he can't be too
far man he's still got to be
hey captain we thought we'd get more
work done in here because you're all
hiding from boyle captain we all think
boyle's a hero but it's very difficult
to be around him right now
i was in the bathroom with him sir it
was a nightmare
hey ah jacob
he's a guy who's always looking for love
and friendship and he needs it now
more than ever but you all turned your
backs on him
and you should all be ashamed of
yourselves i'm sorry those puppies are
so cute
they do undercut your tone a bit sir
oh i think i know what to do with them
you didn't have the idea wholesome yeah
i think you might be able to give these
dogs a good home
you are off the scooter if you have
fallen please call a doctor
captain i don't know if i should okay oh
that tickles
[Music]
are you crying santiago i'm so allergic
can you tell the scooter to call an
amulet
so i went back to the mom's house
unsurprisingly a dead end i got a lot of
work to do peralta
wait we've worked together long enough
that i know how much you hate apologies
i just want to ask you to join the doug
judy case officially
as partners i want to catch this guy and
i can't do it without you
no you can't hmm now i believe i owe you
a thousand push-ups two thousand i don't
care about the push-ups jake
i care that you didn't honor our pack
i've always trusted you and when you did
that it made me feel like you don't
trust me
i know and i'm sorry it won't happen
again no it won't
now go down on the floor what you just
said you didn't care about the push-ups
i changed my mind
tax-packed
a thousand push-ups oh my god dude two
three he's got much better form than i
do
613. here arnold
1000 is so many push-ups i'm never gonna
make it
what am i at 901. thank you captain
oh it's at 2 000. remember i should have
trusted you
well that was another great episode
[Laughter]
that greg has liked for five years yeah
man
shouts out i don't need to change it
royalty free chat
music chris mccloud isn't it
who's chris mccloud the royalty like
he's
yeah which is mcleod chris mccloud
sorry very different name i take it back
i'm sorry
kevin we paid top dollar for that
we did we have and then gotten top
dollar usage at it
uh yeah this was very fun yes yeah it
was really really it was different it
was a different episode
and a refreshing one stephanie beatrice
you're in the craig robinson seat this
is she is
she is quite quite attractive her
her stern uh and badass
you know attitude is certainly an
attractor
i i get you i feel you yeah wow i don't
know it's this episode in particular i
was like
what what happened why am i what what is
going on
flip the switch what is going on here
yeah switch on you
it's okay yeah she's she's gorgeous um
all right pick storyline which one we
start with
uh okay i mean we will then start with
charles and the cast obviously charles
and the cast
and the rest of the cast that was that
was a funny little bit they had going
because
i i think that's a really relatable
thing
you know you know you guys talking about
when you're when you're like in a police
department and then you gotta like work
with your co-workers but you got this
one other police officer who took a
bullet and you're just like dance versus
annoying though
recovery crazy food taste and you're
like i don't want to eat that but i
gotta be polite
no it's the situation where you have uh
someone who you have to help take care
of when they start getting on your
nerves because
the the emotional uh support that
is required and the attention that
they're demanding and then also the
physical ailment yeah it can be
frustrating but you feel
bad about it and so you try to hide it
and you try to just put up with it
but then you can't you know it's one of
those things where yeah you can look bad
um for feeling that way and thinking
that way but i think that's why the bit
works so well because
it's relatable it is relatable maybe not
to this extent where a friend took a
bullet or something but it is relatable
oh absolutely
and i love the way it tied around where
hulk comes out and charles just knows
he's just like yeah everybody i know
what they did
you know cause like there's there's
something to him where it's like
he doesn't even seem he's not like
showing the
level of dejection that makes him feel
and so it makes it that much more sort
of
uh it puts you right with whole like
it's an interesting position to be in
because holt is so much like yeah
this this is the guy who laid down his
life for you
but also it is very understandable and
and i love the way that turned out with
the puppies
ultimately yeah like that was of the
predictable outcomes of this episode
that was the more favorite of mine
yeah i mean all the outcomes were a
little bit predictable like the second
craig robinson started speaking and i
was like
i just think it's craig robinson yeah
it's gotta be craig robinson
but i think it's i think it's cool to
have that angle of you know
they've set up some people to be
potentially recurring
like you got the vulture you got patton
oswalt as a firefighter
and now you got craig robinson here as
uh the pontiac bandit
what i love is that he got away with it
in the end the bandits slipped away
once more and then they set it up where
you have
um peralta and rosa having a
stronger bond and i've never really
associated any of these episodes so far
with peralta and rosa and they talk
about how they were in the academy
together so
oh they have this whole history i wasn't
aware of that they have imbued in these
characters
and um having that that cliffhanger of
i need you to be able to hunt down the
pontiac
bandit like we need to work together on
this case so it gives you something to
look forward to some
specific storyline that is about
investigation
that is about doing detective work and
hunting down a bad guy
so i really love having that angle with
them and to seeing that implementing the
show helps raise both of these
characters and adds a new
a new fresh layer to them and it was so
great because
uh craig robinson even though i never
once
bought that he wasn't the pontiac bandit
i loved that they had them getting along
so well
almost to the point where if he wasn't
the pontiac band and if he wasn't
the criminal maybe peralta and him could
have been friends
yeah absolutely they just kept bonding
throughout the episode and it felt so
natural
like none of uh like craig robinson i'm
so used to him mainly being
the the just a real like um dry
monotone deadpan is the word i've been
looking for a deadpan
uh kind of character and here he brought
like i've seen him throw these shades of
that kind of portrayal before and other
work
but it's not the the kind of performance
i'm used to seeing from him that's
very charming like he's incredibly
flirtatious a little bit giddy a little
bit more
child like and it was it was refreshing
for me to see more of that side of craig
robinson
who's having so much fun and it's a
great mirror effect for the guy who is
the arch nemesis
i mean he seems to have a lot of arch
and embassy uh jake peralta but
this seems to be his ultimate arch
nemesis the guy's been hunting down for
eight years
and he can't seem to catch him and then
he's right there and he slips through
the cracks
i like slips right through his fingers
and i love that at the end
um you know revealing oh this was this
great grand scheme plan the whole time
and craig robinson i thought as a
pontiac band it was great i got one
out of any character that's been
introduced who could be reoccurring
he's the one i most want to see return
that's the one i'm most anxious to see
return
well yeah and it seems like there could
be an even more fun game to come out of
that because maybe it'll be
a kind of thing where they always get
close to catching them and they don't
or i don't know like it seems like
there's more possibility whereas i
imagine like
the vulture showing back up or pat and
oswald showing back up will be kind of
to rely on those specific dynamics
whereas there's something about having
like a maybe recurring criminal
character that could add a special layer
of spice
yeah you know that could be
unpredictable each time to a degree a
thousand percent you hit it on the head
and that's why i
really want him to return like this was
a really fun one uh
for all the different dynamics that you
got here like they i they
they switch up the roles everyone's sort
of playing here
i loved because it's like boyle's
usually the one that they kind of pick
on
and here the whole point is they they
can't
yeah that they want to but they all feel
bad so instead they all
hide and retreat away from him and yeah
boyle's usually like kind of oblivious
uh to the way other people are but he
was clearly aware of
what was going on and i loved like
actually jesus has been live tweeting it
this whole time
such a gina thing to do yeah and
how his performance was handling it i
thought it was aw
i thought it was awesome that he didn't
do any part of his
work to elude that he knows what's going
on
um so it just hits that much harder when
he when you find out he does and it's
like yeah he's
smart enough to know yeah he seems like
he's not gonna delude himself but he's
also the kind to you know trying at
least while there are still a few people
around maybe make the most of it hey
maybe people are enjoying my ethiopian
food
oh they're not you know damn but i'm not
gonna you know make a big thing out of
it like yeah
it was a very dear plot line in a lot of
ways and and as much as i
uh the physical comedy there wasn't my
favorite part of this episode
i did enjoy the way he he played it
because it wasn't like
too wacky and broad with like his
physicalities and stuff like that and i
thought some of the physical psych
like with terry having him in the
bathroom and stuff like that like there
were some pretty funny
yeah just like random psych eggs and
things like that they did with him that
i thought were pretty
i don't want i don't necessarily want
the cast to be a
thing for like several more episodes but
you know i thought there was some fun
and games to be had with it here yeah
overall another solid installment and
they set up a character
that i'm very much looking forward to
see i think i think peralta
it's fun when they mix up uh like who's
teamed up
yeah and i think teaming up peralta and
rosa who are both
really good at their jobs but they have
extremely different approaches to what
they do
um and they both like to play by their
own rules
essentially it was cool seeing them like
it really worked for me here
more than more than him and amy like it
actually like amy you got kind of the
romantic inkling between them
rosa you don't get that yeah and i like
that that you don't get a sense at all
of anything
sexual or romantic between them it's
just
these are two cops are good at their
jobs and they're good at partnering up
together it's like you usually see
peralta
with boyle amy has been with rosa
hitchcock and sully and here
having peralta and rosa made for
something really fresh
and i i i actually think that in terms
of who he's been paired up with that
might be my
my favorite for an actual detective
thing to do an actual character yeah
yeah yeah that was the perhaps the
richest thing for me in this episode
because they did
it's like even when their scenes weren't
about necessarily the funny bits i was
still like
invested and yeah i like the the history
that they established there and it makes
me look forward to
more interesting pairings and whatnot
you know because we there's still
i feel like a number of combinations we
haven't had yet yeah and you have to see
more sincere sides to rosa too that
whole thing about how the push-ups don't
matter to me it's all about
trust that i think that's what this show
has demonstrated what it does so well is
that they
they naturally unveil
more about who their characters are
underneath the comedy
little by little and that's what keeps
you really hooked
like with rosa i loved them i loved the
moment where
jake does go to her where jake does talk
to her about
um you know having to team up it felt
like a real cop moment
yeah yeah absolutely i made a mista i
made a mistake and now
i need your help to fix it yeah it was
about um
it was about learning to trust one
another yeah it was awesome and i took
your k
and i took your case and messed it up
basically yeah yeah yeah
it's beautiful all right guys well what
did you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below
um make sure to subscribe click that
bell thank you everyone's for joining us
over at our patreon appreciate your time
for adding down these highlights and
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]